[Music]
happy Sunday Esther happy Sunday
Georgina how was your week
oh the Lord is with me mm-hmm but the
devil he got his hands on my grandniece
grace oh no mmm
just smoking the reefer doing the
hanky-panky with boys no George Oh
Esther you know that I love all things
that are good and holy but if he doesn't
let go of my grandniece grace I'm gonna
cut the devil's off and shove it any way
mmm with my prayers I know you will Joe
Gina I know you will
how was your week Earl oh you know me
I'm blessed and thankful for every day
all right but you know my grandson Jason
got his self wrapped up in the leathery
claws of Satan not Jason you got
yourself arrested for the spray-painting
and the vandalism oh and I'll tell you I
never raised my hand and anger but if he
don't let Jason go and I'm gonna punch
that Satan in the nuts so hard and wipe
the licking smirk off his horn ass face
mm-hmm with my prayer amen
I know you will after I know you will
but after I gotta tell you someone else
nah let it out you know Esther I have
found serenity in the glory of heaven
yes but my daughter's husband Bernard
has got himself wedged between the cleft
hooves of Lucifer himself she opened up
her laptop computer and found the
pornography we're not the pornography
and saluted the Pinnock appeal was not
on the laptop computer
octagon you running up another veil with
me I am a pacifist under God's request
but if he don't let go of Bernard I'm
gonna sneak up on that bitch-ass Lucifer
right in the midst of his sleep time and
then I'm gonna sit on that mother and
almost spread my booty cheeks on that
pigs face and I'm gonna just pucker up
my stank ho oh and just toops toops
[Music]
brown on his nose to use for target
practice
Oh Georgina Georgina Georgina oh I got
nothing but faith in God in heaven above
but I tell you my son's white crystal
she
herself wrapped up in the fiery wings of
children for every creature on this
planet but he don't let my darling
Krystal go I'm gonna flirt with the
devil Oh Oh show me little bit of
shoulder how you doing
he gonna start looking away I will start
20 stopped working on me like one way
he's gonna be he gonna be drawn in
seduce that then when he least expects
it and I got his trust that's when I'm
gonna ride I'm gonna give him the night
of his life and I ain't never gon [ __ ]
yeah you don't give him this way I'm
gonna give him that way right wing he
about to climax that's when I'm going
off with a divine Kegel with your bling
of course with the prayers yeah but
that's right girl
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you